hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to five nights at
Freddy's help-wanted we are going on a
bit of a treasure hunt we're gonna be
looking for all the tapes who we
possibly can get our hands on which
means that we have to go through each
and every one of these and double check
pretty much everything you shut up
I don't care what you have to say and I
have to make sure that I got all the
coins and all these places got that one
got that one and then that was the one
that was in the monitor here I think I
got everything here so considering that
I think I'm good on the first five
nights at Freddy's 1 I think I've got
everything because I've got eight of the
tapes and I've got 13 of whoa you're
closer baby I've got 13 of 30 coins
which is good which means that I'm not
too far off from where I need to be I
just need a backtrack because I don't
remember what I've got already and if
you can stay far away from me that'd be
great so what I got to do is I've got a
little guy that's telling me where
everything is so apparently five nights
at Freddy's 2 there's a coin that you
can get if you put the mask on shut up
over Oh what right there and there
wasn't tape here but I think I've got
that already I'm gonna let the puppet
get me where is it it would appear on
the desk
okay well got that one hey you're
laughing on left and we're all laughing
five days of phrase three oh three nine
five two four eight let me do that too
just to do it five nights at Freddy's 3
there's a parent oh no no this wrong
it's wrong wrong wrong on going five
nights at Freddy's 3 you remember how
when I play the original there was a
thing in the wall oh [ __ ] there we go
okay three nine five two four
oh and then this should be a tape haha
hey hey
okay there's supposedly one that appears
in the vent I don't know where or how or
why but there apparently is but it might
be caused by a ventilation error I'm not
on represent sure whoa [ __ ] there we go
okay penalize AHA oh wait no I got that
one already okay there mom we're good Oh
[Music]
big booty how are you doing you good I'm
good I hope that you remember me from
last time when I kicked your ass
do you member do you think wow where'd
you go I don't know I don't feel so good
looks like I might need a little help
maybe some mat whoa mouth-to-mouth might
be good you suck
if I win this boss [ __ ] hey there you
are Oh
why are you long I'm not no not so fast
there buddy
boo I win oh [ __ ] you up with that [ __ ]
okay whatever
that's not why I'm here I didn't even
need to die so once I get it I'm just
gonna go enough jump-scares whoo hey
buddy all right we got a new one let's
just listen to him as we go I don't like
you getting close like that but there we
go okay wait I think we did yeah we did
I was told I had three days to finish
Jeremy's work but I know it's just
passing the time they don't really
expect me to do anything it's just to
keep up appearances until the buyout is
complete we have to look like we have
things under control
aha there's another potential
development studio
wants to pick up from here but who knows
what kind of Lies they're being fed to
convince them to do it that's my better
judgment I'm going to do my best to see
what's here okay I try to isolate where
this thing is hiding aha then the next
person that test this do you think you
could have just make one tank being like
hey look out for that thing that's bunny
okay look out for that you know you
didn't need to record it every single
one of these you said something about
file size this is the waste of file size
hi whoa what's here aren't ya hey buddy
[Music]
so in dark rooms nightmare maybe there's
a coin and a tape I don't know if I got
either of them they're here if I look up
oh hi there it is oh [ __ ] there it is
and on the floor to the right apparently
hello hi oh so you're not gonna do a
thing here I don't know why why does
this open whoa [ __ ] off you okay I must
still get what I don't get why why don't
you open I don't know you know what [ __ ]
you baby come get me ma you think I'm
scare you huh
you think I'm scare you yeah come on do
it come on do it
hey come on yeah well you got nothing oh
that's what I thought I thought you got
a whole lot of nothing I thought I got a
whole lot of something you've got hold
on nothing go next is parts and service
and this I think there's something in
all of these that I've missed because
apparently and I didn't know this maybe
just because I didn't think of trying
[Music]
you're doing a lot of this I need you to
do some of this okay
I'm becoming numb to you you ain't gonna
sass me because I am way to Sasebo so
I'm just gonna go ahead and go into
Chico's because I know that there's
something there that I can do wink so
apparently if you do this here you go go
on take it thank you for that eat it oh
I'm eating it all right there you go yay
all the pizza I'm a glutton what can I
say chica chugged love it so apparently
there's a bunch of stuff here that I
didn't get okay it's funny actually it's
funny you're gonna laugh you're gonna
laugh I got that one there's that but
behind Freddy's left ear all right thank
you soon too soon too soon
that's so funny behind his left ear
that's adorable okay but we got another
tape so you're evil you were real
proximal to me
how about in the nightmare world are you
any closer no cuz you suck alright take
time I like tapes today was my last day
of beta testing and the anomaly that
I've been seeing is nowhere to be found
mm-hm but after inspecting some of the
files it seems that it's attached itself
to these lock great yeah that's good
yeah that's good to know that can't be
an accident so now I have to make a
choice
uh-huh I leave these logs here for you
to find or do I try to purge this thing
myself by destroying the logs I've
chosen the latter
that was a mistake that was very clearly
a mistake you dumb why we if you knew
that it was attached to the lawsuit with
these locks aren't important these vlogs
are nonsense they're just you
complaining about your job that's all
I'm hearing my god
my god apparently oh wow there it is I
don't know how I didn't notice that when
I was going through this before but
there's another tape
boink hi you are very close the weakest
hey listen buddy listen you are big I am
a verage I'm average okay by creating a
protected area to store these logs apart
from the games uh-huh effectively gave
this thing a safe place to hide itself
so you can't destroy them right yeah I
might be able to do something else now
that it's attached itself uh-huh Oh your
ideas have been going so good so far
great ideas Babu whatever your name is
it seems that on multiple occasions now
you have disappeared from the authorized
boundaries of the fazbear's virtual
experience aha what ask that you not do
it again
no you can ask oh you can ask all right
I just ain't gonna follow you know what
I'm sayin about that so with foxy as I
discovered before has a quirky little
fun trick that you're able to do in
there is you're able to do this this
first whoa amazing
oh you're harmless whoa wow what a
tantrum that took us to you yeah
whatever doing yeah yeah yeah whatever
nerd I ain't even afraid anymore I am
big brave I'm big brave and yours big
also but I am big brave so that was
another coin that was not another tape
so Vette repair in here there's
apparently both a coin and a tape I may
have gotten the tape in this one I'm not
sure I just gotta check the Oh
well nerd stooop oh wait I hate this one
oh I forgot I hate this one oh I hate
this one just screw you okay
you're not even scary in here give me
that [ __ ] yeah that's what I want that's
what I want you know what I even worried
ain't even worried about nothing I
didn't worry about nothing whatever nerd
yeah you coming nerd you like you some
on this Oh what's that I hear death oh
yeah right
nerd ha ha thought so nerd oh look at
the grab no ceilings real cool huh
what's this Squidward oh how you you
ain't a nerd are you what's that I hear
a nerd approaching well come at me nerd
that's what I thought
that's what I thought that's what I
thought oh what a nerd don't like me I'm
rad rad as hell okay
so this is where it starts to get
complicated because it's not here's
where it starts to get complicated after
this it starts to get complicated
because there okay got that
hey bub hey how you doing you're good
got this yeah I got the tape up here
nerd nerd whoa big nerd big nerd big
nerd okay so I think I got the tape in
there I'm pretty sure so now it gets
complicated because the rest of all the
goodies I think anyway are in wow you
are real close real close I think are in
the nightmare world
yay magic 807 him it's not a magic
8-ball
it's just a normal eight ball stupid for
the next few things that I need to do I
need to finish this and get to this
level
so mangle you big nerd I'm coming for
you it's not my nightmare
it's your nightmare oh and this is going
to be such a good nightmare oh yeah I
don't like this I know you're there
whoa [ __ ] oh [ __ ] wait whoa whoa what
the [ __ ] okay
oh [ __ ] hey hey hey whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa what the [ __ ] okay um hang on oh
[ __ ] wait a moon [ __ ] minute oh [ __ ]
okay hey wait a [ __ ] why are you okay
I don't know what the [ __ ] that is so
that's good that's good I've got to what
is this
red oh [ __ ] off red blue green red blue
green red got it what it was different
right
of course yeah that makes sense haha
nerd nerd alert
nerd alert 72 degrees nerd alert them
nerd alert nerd alert
give me some oh I hate that you see what
I hate this right here I don't like this
that right there not my favorite right
there not cool don't know why but that's
not cool don't like it at all okay all
right goodbye yeah so that was good hi
you seem even closer but maybe this is
my brain playing tricks on me oh my god
I did wait did I do they lied to us
they lied to all of us they told us that
the whole point of this VR game was to
undo the bad PR done by a rolled indie
game developer supposedly made up a
bunch of crazy stories that tarnish the
brand ah that's not true at all in their
hands to develop this VR game and clear
their name they sent us some things I
don't think they intended us to see such
as a hard drive containing emails
between fazbear entertainment and a
certain indie developer fazbear
entertainment hired the game developer
those indie games were designed to
conceal and make light of what happened
this isn't just an attempt to rebrand
it's an elaborate cover-up a campaign to
discredit everything huh so by the indie
developer are you talking about good old
Scott Scott by creating a protected area
just yeah I got already read that one
okay so that was a new one I did get a
new one I didn't even remember that I
got any one okay but that's cool all
right so Scott was trying to make light
of the whole situation but then oh oh
this is all true all right entered come
for you baby we're gonna do this we're
gonna get this just fine you and me oh
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh hey I told you how
much I hate that
what hi how are you doing can I have
that high-five boink
okay cool great anything else there that
I need to worry about all right no great
this is wonderful
love that oh I'm standing on air I guess
it's gonna be the same I'm going up yeah
okay great great great oh oh
help poink poink poink the boys well
done in day that's me maybe that's me
always doing the good in the will okay
oh [ __ ] okay
um oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
don't do it goodbye goodbye goodbye
goodbye goodbye goodbye goodbye oh okay
you're fine
why are you okay oh okay so apparently
the first thing is something's gonna be
in the middle that's all I know
something's gonna be in the middle I'm
ready for it I'm watching for it I just
gotta grab it when it's there
whoo hi okay that's baby's arm that's
good okay gonna grab some gonna grab
some money Brad I'm told I'm okay
what am i that's on the NER is that that
your ground oh hi hi bone head on buddy
what's happening there was nothing it Oh
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
the head what the [ __ ] and you go there
I'm gonna get that hi hello put that
there
who's that right there no there and then
in there I gotta grab this first for
that and then this that done and what
happened in left side maybe it was a
here oh [ __ ]
what was that okay do I grab anything
what is done [ __ ] off hi oh my god Oh Oh
God motion trigger boiler room that's
really cool and all but uh
Oh Frick all right um three to the one
rotate one around
okay I'm going this fast a second I did
it apparently I forgot that it was that
easy I okay all right so this one's just
a matter of rotating and three times I
remember I guess going this boy kiss and
then doing kiss something like that I
think now remember and then to turn that
with done
there we go easy peasy yeah and then
this one's just pushing a button oh hi
whoever you are hi okay goodbye 72
degrees
[Music]
okay so I didn't get [ __ ] on that level
probably cuz I skipped I think what
happened is I wasn't I was not supposed
to skip I think what happened was I was
supposed to be looking down the center
no Skippy let me just confirm I know
skip
I know skip I not skip some additions of
the secondary service elevator but the
comfort of the mean got it I'm just
gonna get one more coin from this oh
okay you and then you were here oh okay
look Wow hi that's that's all oh no wait
I won't be able to see it that's right
okay let's go get you get you whatever
you are somewhere in there yes yes I'm
done with all y'all oh hi boo kiss get
BAE come on kill me I put my head in
your mouth nerd nerd alert looks like we
got a nerd and I'll nerd I see you and
nerd huh
you got something to say huh speak into
my good ear huh speaking of my good but
hole come on what you got oh okay how
about this nerd I can't figure it out
and nerd hey nerd I can't get it can you
teach me
oh you can't teach to the beats oh do
you think I'm gonna get this here why
don't I see this you know Oh No
nerd boink all right so that is another
tape in the bag and you are probably
gonna be okay you're not even there
you're not even there let's just go
ahead and listen to it I ran a
fragmentation program on the area of
memory that was storing these logs for
you I effectively broke the files into
pieces
AHA and broke the anomaly along with it
right that means that you won't have my
warnings to guide you but hopefully it
also means that this anomaly is a virus
or whatever it is will remain broken and
I'm able to do more damage okay do you
see the problem with that logic
number one you made these logs after you
already did this and you knew that the
logs were bad you're that you're you're
speaking that you just did it when you
said at tape 10 that it's no good to
happen so you're trying to guide me
through the process of these things
happening but you knew halfway through
that this [ __ ] was no good and then you
kept doing more you see how that don't
make sense we've made a lot of progress
as it turns out the final tapes are
available in this place right here in
there the final tapes but to get to
there I'm certain I have to be oh this
[ __ ] so I'm gonna hang this one here for
now just for now I don't know where the
other coins are they're all over the
place so I'm not surprised that I
haven't found them specifically in all
of them but for now we have done good we
have called out everyone in here for
their Nerdist nature and that is the
most important thing that I could ever
think of but at the same time we've got
more to dive deeper in this game but
maybe it won't be so bad as we thought
it'll be a little harder for sure but
fine and obviously up to the
you all know who I am oh yeah fine so
thank you everybody so much for watching
check out more five nights at Freddy's
stuff that I've done linked in the
description
stay tuned for much more five nights at
Freddy's and for us to tackle the final
challenge of this game thank you
everybody so much and as always we'll
see you we who else is there I will see
you in the next video bye bye
[Music]